o dólar mais votar
bom dia eu já sabia que ia ser difícil
pois deixa agora é mais difícil ainda
não é qualquer maneira e este é o tempo
todo que eu tinha para dizer isto é uma
escola
você é isso que eu devia transitar de um
powerpoint e excel powerpoint que está
aqui atrás nem vocês vão ter que
imaginar completamente
imaginem que está aqui um powerpoint
excel e powerpoint tem três crianças na
escola nessa aula é e consegue imaginar
eu não eu vou ter que ler isto porque
não consegue ver estes números são muito
número eu devia ter mesmo trazendo um
powerpoint mas a fundação francisco
manuel dos santos eles um estudo
comparativo divulgado assim há poucos
dias sobre o número de horas que as
crianças passam numa sala de aula em
portugal e noutros países é desde a
coreia do sul e irlanda
somos nas contas dos investigadores
investigadores neste caso da fundação um
caso extraordinário porque com o seguro
e com singapura o ultrapassamos o somos
os únicos mesmo ultrapassar a meta dos
900 horas de aulas e mais 900 horas de
aula mais as contas dos investigadores
porém foram feitas não com base nas
análises das escolas em realidade das
escolas mas com base na legislação o que
no caso português é um erro fatal
ou seja as crianças as nossas crianças
estão facto sendo poucas e rosas as
tensões que também usar pelo menos sete
horas por dia na escola ou seja elas
estão
1.155 horas entre meados de setembro e
meados de junho
confinados a um espaço escolar são mil e
400 horas por ano letivo cinco irmãos
aqui as horas de almoço que cobra em uma
grande maioria das crianças
ou seja em média estão cerca de 5 mil
horas em que é também por cada nove
meses de vida das crianças portuguesas
entre os seis e os nove anos são
passados entre os muros das escolas só
durante os primeiros quatro anos de
escolaridade
com este número era evidente que eu
tinha que ter trazido o powerpoint para
ser melhor mas os números são muito
fáceis de encontrar muito muito fáceis
de encontrar este e outros músicos
aquilo que é difícil encontrar era
aquilo que eu queria começar o
powerpoint que eram três crianças
lembranças dentro de uma sala
isto é cada vez mais difícil
temos aqui um problema podemos já por
parte do problema das horas a quantidade
tempo passamos dentro da escola
como vêem perante estes números aqui
dizer não é só senta é é absolutamente
incrível menta e portanto não é falta
tempo que temos o que temos falta é
provavelmente encontrar outras formas de
estar na escola e de conseguir que o
tempo que gastamos seja um tempo em que
nós consigamos rio desculpa pra mim não
é esta questão de colocar no centro dos
curricula não matérias e cada vez mais
matérias mas se colocar pontes de
confluência não é uma questão menor é
uma questão para mim uma questão central
é claro que o que eu trago aqui ao
contrário todos aqueles que me
antecederam
não é uma história de sucesso é uma
história de fracassos
mas é uma história do fracasso tal e
qual como é que tenho pregão com ele uma
relação muito especial como é que um
grande futuro ganhou o prêmio inova
alcançava 1.800 dizia que era fracassar
fracassará melhor falhar a melhor está
esta capacidade que nós temos de buscar
às vezes sentimos muito improvável
forças e idéias é aquela que contraria
muito aquilo que a escola faz com que a
escola faz é fácil enquadrava e dentro
deste colorado coloca o número
substancial perguntas essas perguntas
não saia fora do coral as respostas às
perguntas estão sempre dentro do
quadrado e portanto com quadrado médio
em quadra da escola o colorado médio é é
nossa capacidade de encontrar dentro da
quadra
as respostas certas as perguntas certas
que são aquelas talento quadrado
enquanto cobrava não se nota nada o que
vai lutar daqui a alguns anos quando as
crianças agora tiveram em 22 a 20 e 31
20 anos e tiveram que ir a uma
entrevista de emprego para uma empresa
que não sabemos que aquela vai fabricar
armas para fabricar alguma coisa e
portanto precisa de empregados e 800 e
perguntando sobre sua capacidade de se
relacionar com os outros a capacidade de
buscar outras idéias e capacidade de
articular e de se transformar em coisas
novas e então no final não pra casa eu
não sei muito bem porque de facto como é
que é possível melhorar pra casa da paz
tanto gente tirou sempre sites a novos
exames
há qualquer coisa que não bate bem agora
vai o que não bate bem esse sistema é
isso que estou a imaginar atrás de mim
continuou ver o paulo pan espero eu
estou vendo aqui só tem que fazer coisas
sempre senti sempre sente que está atrás
de mim é facto esta idéia
de que se nós colocarmos só continuamos
a sobrecarregar as mesmas perguntas e
encontrar as mesmas respostas dentro
cuadra continuamos internamento a fazer
isso
somos cada vez melhores dentro do
quadrado experiências que as pessoas
votarão aqui hoje são experiências soas
que saíram fora do quadrado
aquilo que nós temos que esperar é que
se saia fora do quadrado seja fora deste
quadrados vão buscar respostas
por isso aquilo que os proponho aqui o
que eu proponho sempre a toda a gente é
que se coloca no centro da escola no
centro do currículo se coloquem as
expressões artísticas
o que quer dizer aqui dois mitos que
temos que estar em diretamente 1 éder e
há uma uma faceta trabalho trabalho
trabalho árduo trabalho trabalho e outro
lado a presença de cristo são universos
completamente disparate é mentira
todos nós sabemos que a mentira não há
nenhuma exploração entre o trabalho eo
prazer ou seja qualquer um de nós possa
adiantar criando certas circunstâncias é
articular de forma a que este trabalho
seja um prazer
depois a outra é o outro grande mito faz
com que freqüentemente o discurso é que
quando nós temos prazer em aprender as
coisas facto não estamos a aprender nada
de importante
o que estamos a aprender são coisas não
estão limão espécie uma brincadeira e
com esta brincadeira nada se aprende
também não é provar é exatamente o
contrário disto estes mitos e muitos
outros podemos encontrar são muitos
explicou roy abrigamos assim as relações
das pessoas e as doações das pessoas
dentro da escola as ações das pessoas
com a escola e as razões da escola com
as pessoas que lhe são estranhos
esta conclusão cada vez é mais nítida é
digamos fatal
não agora
mas daqui a 20 anos
quando pensamos em colocar o currículo
desculpa quando pensamos em colocar no
centro do currículo
as atividades expressivas temos que
fazer ainda uma outra distinção é aquela
do ensino vocacional daquilo que
realmente é aprender a dominar o
instrumento aprender a dominar uma forma
de expressão artística qualquer aquilo
que eu estou a falar não é vício
aquilo que eu estou a falar é de se
misturar tudo se colocar no centro da
escola
tudo misturado essa capacidade de
misturar tudo até e essa capacidade de
misturar tudo é aquela que faz com que
as crianças e os adultos consigam
encontrar fora do quadrado
outras referências na realidade o que
até faz é isso mesmo é fazer propostas
do ponto de vista para serem
confrontados com outros pontos de vista
estejam estes pontos de vista onde
estiverem
quando temos por exemplo eu não queria
passar o tempo faltando 2 minutos e 32
segundos quando temos por exemplo um
poema como contestamos por exemplo a
pessoa pensamos fernando pessoa julga
preparei pra ele pra pagar esta língua
portuguesa português
depois uma surpresa torneiras a poesia
os quiserem uma poesia portuguesa do
século 20 é de 160
nós somos confrontados ao corpo foram
campos uma criança com 6 anos com um
poema como por exemplo o poema piauí que
é exatamente no momento em que está a
aprender a contar até dez
então posso ver o piau eo piauçu francos
ou é síndico pela se eu passar este
minuto
eu tenho jogo mas hoje não tem piada
nenhuma num problema piauí voltei pro
votos
o papel é sim toda a gente que tem as
mãos frias deve tê lá dentro das pias
via número um para quem mexe as ovelhas
em jejum
número dois para quem bebe diz 'os de
boi ter número 3 para cães pira só uma e
vence dia número 4 para quem manda as
vendas ao teatro pia 15 para quem coma
chave do trinco ia número seis para quem
espanca idéia com bons raios via número
17 que encanta quero que a tepco criados
e do recto pia número 8 para quem parte
nozes quando é 8 bi e número 9
para quem se parece com uma couve de
número 10 para quem cola selos nas unhas
dos pés e como as mãos já não estão
frias
fomos as tampas nas pias
temos que arranjar uma proposta nova
para colocar estas coisas culpa temos
que arranjar uma prateleira nova para
tocar essas coisas mas elas são segundo
elemento da temática poesia porque se é
conhecer o nome de fernando pessoa e por
descobrir outras coisas a partir daí é
tudo junto e precisamente é tudo junto o
que está no meio
agora já passou o tempo peço desculpa e
espero que consigam imaginar há três
crianças r dentro de uma sala
obrigado